Yes can we have the next question from the
sister I am Doctor Pooja Arora I am
from Sine Hospital I am a
physiotherapist so I totally agree with you just a
small question when a Mohammad
prophet attended his prophethood and as you said he was a
common man before he attended
prophethood by that time is it that Quran
which is the word of God has enlightened
only Muslims because God cannot be partial
so what was the rest of the world doing when
Mohammad prophet was enlightening a
small sect of people and is it that really a
long time is being taken for the rest of
the sector of society to just get enlightened
to this word of God and how many years would
the non muslims like
Hindus, pat
Hindus pictures but and Ram bhagwan what ever but it
is a concept and they have to be
enlightened about it that it is one Hinduism
Also follows an almighty which is a power a
divine power but unfortunately it is been
given in various forms so this
enlightenment if Quran helps a Hindu to know this
enlightenment it is fabulous
sister very good question and very important question she said that if
Quran is really a
great book if it is the word of almighty god then why when it came
to prophet Mohammad it was only meant
for that small group or not Arabs
of that time only Muslims why not for the
whole world how will it take sister the
Quran was never revealed only for the
Muslims and for the Arabs the Quran was
revealed for the whole of unity it is mentioned
in Sura Ibrahim chapter number 14 verse number
and in Sura Ibrahim chapter number 14 verse
number 52 in Ra Ch number 185 and Jamaat ch number
39 No. 41 The Quran was not for the
whole of human time It is giving
references not in this verse The Quran was not
for the Muslim Arabs The Quran was for the whole of human time It is giving references not in this verse The Quran was
not for the
Muslim Arabs The Quran was for the whole of human time It is giving references not in this verse The Quran was not for the Muslim Arabs
The Quran was for the whole of human time It is giving references not in this verse The Quran was not for the Muslim Arabs The Quran was for the whole of
human time It is giving
references not in this verse It is the duty of every Muslim
that should convey the message  Almighty God to the
human
be so one more thing all the time but better than never, better than never and everyone can not be a
practicing Muslim his
name is Abdullah Zakar Mohammad Sultan
but I may not be a practicing
Muslim similarly as you correctly said in
Hindu you do follow scripture but yet the reason we are the maximum
followed not only by lip
service but in practice today it is Islam
number
one in numbers
Christianity it is close to 2 billion
Muslims claiming is 1.3 billion but the
people practicing the religion number one is
Islam percentage wise it is the largest
so those lectures are mainly two small percentage
of Muslims who are not following Islam
correctly to get them closer to Islam and
to those non Muslims we want to give the
message of peace the message of
love and proof to the world that there is only one God
the ultimate peace can only come if you
submit a will to almighty  God is the only way to
ultimate peace in this world and after so that the reason sister
we are having such conference we have
satellite channel Peace TV
every day more than 60 million people are watching it
so at least on the day of judgement we have Allah
Sula Ya Rab we do our best when we could we at least
gave the message every day to
6 million people and today the message is with
you sister so tomorrow on the day of judgement I can tell
to the mighty God I gave the message to
the sister whether you accept it or not in your
hand
sister done, thank you very much sir just one more thing because
God is impartial so on the
day of judgement as you did a politics that non
muslim should be given first priority to ask the
questions God is impartial so if
Hindus stop believing in idols and
pictures and they start believing in the
almighty who has got  No form no shape and
on the day of judgement it is that they will
not be behaved as Muslims by God no it
is not like that it is the concept
which is there in Hinduism the misbelief
that is follow in forms but if Hindu following
Hindu religion is not color but
following because your aim is God he is the
supreme he should not have form but if this
message is reach to Hinduism you have one it very good
sister very good question thank
you sir regarding we are being partial it is partial there can be
two different views from
your side because partial please ask if aa wa
pal id l t Allah sula I gave these
directly one to one y no so he d he d
believe so we believe sister but why we are really we are partial to be emotional but
get the message if not
100% 90 per yt less  So we are partial to be Islam right
sir so what we are not coming back to que
sister teri good right if the Hindus believe in
one God do not believe in idols do not believe
in images do not believe in statues on the
day of judgement what we are Muslims correct
you are following part of Islam correct if
you read the Hindu scripture from the Hindu
scripture there is another messenger to come
and the coming of prophet Mohammad peace be upon
him has been professed in various places he is
prophesied in Bhavishya Purana parva th khand th chapter
th loka f he prophesying
th chapter th shloka 10 27 he is professed in the
Atharva
Veda chapter number 21 verse number s Atharva
Veda chapter number 21 verse number s
in various places he is mentioned by name
no less than 100 times as Mohammad in the Hindu
scripture time does not permit me to mention in the
references  Mention of Kalki Avatar in
Kalki Purana Chapter number two verse number 4
5 7 9 11 and 15 It says that there is another
incarnation of Kalki Avatar. The father name of Kalki Avatar shall be the servant
of God Vishnu Yash Translate to Arabic as
Abdullah and the name of the father of Salam the
mother name of this Kalki Avatar shall be Sumati that gives peace
and serenity. The name is
Amina and the name of Prophet Muhammad Salam that is the name of Prophet this person will be born on the 12th day of Muhammad the 12th the prophet he is the first caliph It says that he will be
born in a place which is peaceful
in Mecca He will be born in the house of the
chief of Mecca that is the Quresh tribe It says that he will go
northwards from a
cave and come back and Prophet Muhammad Salam will come
from Mecca to  Madina and came back on
and on talking about Kalki avatar so you
believe in one person la ila illallah you also have to
believe in Muhammad Rasulallah
thank you sir thank you and if you do this you keep
your name what ever your name was
preethi what ever name sister what is the
name sister Pooja Pooja you keep your name don't
change your name but indeed you will be a
Muslim changing your name is not
required so the concept concept of one
God no statue no images last final
messenger prophet Mohammad inshallah on the
day of judgement you will go to heaven with your
name Pooja so the pathways are different the only thing is the
goal should be the same that is what I
believe for the goal pathways are different if both
the different pathways go to the same goal meet
at the same goal yes sir that is what I want to
see the roads don  lead to Rome
sister fine you think it will lead so if you think falsely i have to correct
you i don't believe no sir sister if you say
you are hindu
by definition hindu i am a person who live in
india no sir it is not like the sister
hindu is geographical definition you don't know i know i am
hindu biographical definition
i am hindu
geographically
sister the word hindu was first used by
darb there are many arab r they call me hindi no
i go hindi hindi
hindu the word hindu was first used by
the arab r they came to india it's used
by the p to describe the people living in
india so geographically hindu but if you tell
me rightly hindu is a mis noma swami
vivekananda said the right term is the veda
so as far as you follow the right things in the
veda believe in one god and believe in
prophet mohammed sallam by deed you are a
muslim so the religion can't be powerful the
ultimate power is allah right ultimate
power is god  and the religion of God and the
religion of God is ultimate religion so the
religion of God is not Islam the religion of God is
not Islam if Islam is Arabic word which
is hurting you you keep Islam
aside no no I it is not hurting me I am
telling you not hurting me if it is not
hurting you nobody no sir it is a park
word in itself how it can hurt anybody at least not an
educated girl mashallah you are
educated girl sister yes thank you so much thank
you sir sister Islam means submitting a
will to God so Islam is a problem keep
Islam aside but submit to God Allah
says in the Quran in sare al Imran chapter 3
verse number 19 inan dana in the la Islam the
only religion the only way of life accepted
in the sight of Allah submitting lam gad yes badar
Mr Naik this is my self doctor
Suryakant Pawar from Senj Hospital
thanks  For the Nice and Enlightening Lecture
about the Quran is God's Word as you mention in
Quran is God's Word I just want to ask
you who is the creator of God what is the
origin of
God r good question if Quran is the word
of God who is the creator of God very good
question if I ask you brother that your friend
John he gave birth to a child can you guess the
child was a girl or a boy your friend John
gave birth to a child in the hospital can
you guess was it a girl or a
boy guess guess no girl or a boy I can't guess sorry I may not guess try at least
50%
you will get right or one half chance ok tell
me boy boy whether can a
man give birth to a child
no so is it a girl and a boy but the name can be
follow female I am asking you your
friend
John I don't know any one female called by
John no we can  Call no ok suppose a friend who is a
boy is a man he went to hospital he gave
birth to a child was it a girl and
a boy
girl can a man give birth to a child badar no now you
understood a man can give birth to
a child so where the question of it be girl
and boy so by definition gad is
uncreated
birth to a child i.e. girl and boy the question is
logical because by definition a man can not give birth
to a child so where the
question of girl and boy so by definition
gad is an every cut thing
creator gad did not have
creator their argument was a never ever said everything
creator i said every cut
the creator but the gad is unk by
definition the moment action who is the cut or gad he
not unk by
definition gad is unk by definition ok then
next question from the brother  In the back
my name is peter i am student of
religious
philosophy my question is on the textual
authenticity of the quran first n abu bakr
commanded to gather the text together he did the but they also
written in al bukhari volume
number f page 96 abdul ibn masud he was
the authority mention by mohammed he gathered a
text then salim the freed slave he gathered the
text and
also ub in kaab master writer mention by
mohammed and there also other people compile the
text but n usman became the
caliph he ordered zayd to make replica seven
replica of his text and sent it to the
different
parts and ordered dos previous text
to be
burnt now if
dos master writer compiled the quran
and usman ordered dos text to be
burnt now there is a question on the
authenticity of the quran mashala no ine mashala
mashala many of muslims n no
name  You know now it is easy to go on the internet
Jesus Christ said in the Gospel of John
chapter number 8 verse 2 seek the truth and
the truth shall be free You now on the internet there are many
people go on the internet there various websites we are
speaking about Islam they go they get
the name and they say no problem
brother no problem brother a further question is
concern the people who compiled the Quran they were a
group of Sahaba the comp of the Prophet whoever Prophet got revelation he
repeated it
to scribe and
support and Prophet Mashala's good memory
Allah's memory he repeated it down
the Prophet personally riff riff
ok read it now curt so Prophet
personally was alive whoever was
written narrated whether it was
perfect and not under personal supervision and scribe they were
selected by the Prophet and that
revelation came in 22 ha  yers l wa
down and later compile one book l supervised
by pr in the order now later on many a
people never the prophet said verses was revealed they write these
notes many many saba but this private note
of the other people not checked by the proof so the teacher
give the notes 100 student copy how do i not rate if i am
giving lecture some people
note down chapter no number charat no number ha
fast note down and in do ref they se o
doctor nayak ya said this reference wad a
set have i checked so what has been later on many a verse
of the quran was many people that they
o note to be real quran
andan ilam spread people do not know which wa real
quran so at the time what the compiled copy wad they hq
ng scrib it was then in the hand of
wife of
prophet and then uman
copy edition so it b different part o  and then he said
what ever copy you have, whether it is right
or wrong, you burn it because that has been
verified, so people had their own
notes, suppose someone makes notes of my
lecture, those people making their notes may be
80 per cent, 90 per cent, 100% correct,
100%, it is very difficult, so if I give you now this
is the
book of my lecture, you are getting book now
Quran and Modern Science authenticated by me,
your notes you throw it away, why do you
require the notes, I gave you book any, or getting
the full lecture, you are getting part of the
lecture Quran and Modern Science, not that part, I will tell you
brother, throw those notes away, this
is correct, authenticated by me, Dr. Zakir
Naik, my book is same way, what was written by the Prophet, the Prophet Muhammad (peace be upon him)
Osman Alaabi
please with him he said the copy should be burned that does not mean there were many Qurans
one
Quran was revealed but people do not give their
own notes there are differences so that in the region now one
of the ten copies is even today present in the
Coptaki Museum in Istanbul so this
and you check it today it is at least the same word
to word letter to letter that way even if you
try to change it you cannot because
today there are millions of people who know
the Quran by heart and here in audios mashallah they have many who know
the Quran by heart even if you burn the copy
you get it together you get together a regional
Quran which can be reproduced
but is it the same with the master recited
at the time of Muhammad and the Zai text
was compiled only after the death of Muhammad it is
totally too late what will have to be
Relight he was appointed as the chief of the
scribes there were many scribes together he was
appointed as the chief and this was personally
verified by Prophet Muhammad (peace be upon him) and
later on at the time of Hatim Abu Bakr Allah please pass with him it was
made into a book form because at that
time there was not paper there was no
pen it was written on parchment on bone or
blade on different material then it was later
transferred to one uniform material
and made into a book form now that
people live in the group of people and a
leader like brother Zakir Naik Assalam Alaikum
ta kin Gaddan teacher by profession
first of all let me Congratulations
[praise]
Islam is truly the way of life then our
people are taking so long in believing and
accepting it like
good queen Quran word of good
Islam  The reason why people are taking so long is
accepting it as the
straight path. I don't love it to
follow. Perception differs. The perception of each individual differs.
For example, a person who may
not be following
Islam. If I accept Islam, he may be an
alcoholic. I have to stop having
alcohol. I have to stop going out with
girls and dating. So then that will prevent him. So what he
thinks is okay, fine,
Islam may be good but I don't want to
stop alcohol. I don't want to stop going out and
flirting with girls. I don't want to stop having sex. So when you learn they may be certain that someone may not be an
alcoholic. He may not be having sex. He thinks okay, now I
accept Islam that means
for 40 years. I fool or better not accept
Islam. Some of me think if I am what will my
friend say, what will my mother say, what will
my  Father say so all the obstacles are superior only if
you can overcome this obstacle can
you accept the truth so why don't you have to
lose the message the message is clear the message is logical it is absolutely
clear but there are other things which are in their
baggage a person has to be so
strung if this is the truth I am having to
accept this I have to leave my other non
muslim friends and believe me sister this is
only perception and non muslim
accepted ilm and yet the old friend
and people tell me oh zakir don't speak to non
muslim u lose the friendship I got very good
non muslim friend also mashala
respect me you have appreciated me mashala
you are non muslim so my job is to
present the truth and one more thing quran
clearly mention in sir baqara chapter number two
verse number 256 lakan there judge no compuls
religion  Truth stands clear from error
our job is to present the truth whether a person
accepts it or not it depends upon him if
almighty god wanted everyone to
accept it it is very easy it is mentioned in the
Quran in Sir Yes Chapter No. 10 Verse No. 99
if he wanted he could have made the human be
believers very easy it is
the
test from Allah in Quran in Quran
in Quran Chapter No. 67 Verse No. 11 it
Allah gave death and life to test
of your good deeds so this life is test
for your afterlife the person believe the truth everything you believe the truth you don't follow you follow
80% but you may follow very few
people follow 100% even the muslim do not follow
100% some muslim bad habit yet they
muslim so what do they believe the
major points  Of Oneness of God and Believing
in the Last and Final Messenger and
Believing in the here after two three points are the
most important sister and the same thing I'll tell you sister you ask me the question I'll ask you the same question then what is
taking you so much time to
accept the sister Doctor Zakir Nayak I would just like to tell you something that here
with your blessings I accept Islam
and repeat the Kalma La ilaha illallah
Mohammad Rasool
Allah Mashallah sister may Allah may
Allah bless
you Allah Jannah inshallah
[praise]
wake up Allah Subhan just Amen may we have
next question from the brother
firstly sir congratulations for your this
program I am Advocate Shivaji Sapka
from Beed
Maharashtra this program is peace for
lover I get opportunity to ask
question but my question is not related
Quran yes
sir there are  Lots of Marathi speakers
I also speak
Marathi what is the role of IRF means
Islamic Research
Foundation what I am doing for Marathi and
non
Muslim good question of Maharashtra
asking are we doing Marathi can and what are
non Muslim as Marathi can and are [ __ ] what we what to do
but taking much more books in Marathi
by others because I can understand
Marathi and speak
Marathi I am able to
speak Marathi but I also
love Marathi but some speak
Marathi I can request you to speak
and convey the message of peace in
different languages ​​the training program
is in English and many people no three four
languages ​​so the training program is in
English some times in Urdu and Hindi then he goes if he is coming from
South Africa
from Africa then he speaks in African
language many people are coming from other
parts of the world from Malaysia they have come they have come
From USA they have come from
Singapore from Saudi Arabia from
Philippines so I do know so what I do I am to
convey the message in English I tell the people
to convey I am requesting you brother convey my
message what you have heard here to
those people in Marathi you are doing a favor
to me inshallah that's the first question come
to the second question what are we doing
for non muslims again we are doing much what ever limited we can do they so much to be done
two organization is big
mashallah we have more than 2000 years yet I am to say nothing we are very small
organization very small we have organize conference we are giving
firsts to non muslims because
you are a VIP guest
special
guest you today are more closer to me are
muslims we because I have to convey Allah
will ask me no day of judgement yes convey these days
Not so I am going to the right level best to convey
personally not this level further this conference is a
10 day conference we invited non
muslims and we mention in the poster all faith
welcome people of all faiths are
welcome but in the question session we give them first
preference we give them priority so the
doubts can be cleared even the muslims
doubts the muslims are angry with me what now as we are going to the right level tomorrow
no problem ok tomorrow means we will
see after 10 days
so what we have beside giving the message
to people mal b
mon 60 my pop wang lai but yat wa aan ila
fund t washd d w art tal bl b a explain eter d
true spaces to u but sir yes
brother the next question my name
is sahil i am a graphic designer i am a poet may
peace be on you doctor zakir i always
wanted to say this i've got a chance  By
God's grace today I love you Doctor Zakir
I love you very very much and I thank you may
peace be upon you brother and I thank you for I
too love you bar I too love you brother thank you
and I thank you for the ample amount of
knowledge I've got going through your lectures
from my friends from my sister Nagma
and the slight bit of
knowledge  Fusion between the word of God and the people who
believe in the concept of Judgement Day like a
small question we believe like the
Muslims believe in the Judgement Day the dead will be put to
life in
them and some of the Muslims believe that it will be on
the first night in the grave
the dead will be put to life and be buried and some of the Muslims believe that it will be on the first night in the grave the dead will be put to life and be buried and some of the Muslims believe that it will be on the first night in the grave the dead will be put to life and be buried and some of the Muslims believe that it will be
on the first night in the grave so I have quite different opinions about life and day of judgement not being buried and will it be in the grave brother i shan o kabar alan imran chapter number that every soul shall have its punishment but the final reckoning will be on the Day of Judgement this life is just a
matter of play and deception but the final
hisab kitab final judgement is on the Day of Judgement what we have to do we may get part
of the punishment in this world part of the
reward in this world part of the reward
in the grave part of the recompense  The grave but the
final ultimate judgment is on the Day of
Judgment the final total of good and bad will be
recorded on the Day of Judgment and then
based on your deeds you will either go to heaven
and hell some of this will be given in this
world some in the grave but the final
accounting will be on the Day of Judgment hope to answer the question
thank you yes sister hi I am an
American student studying
culture and theology and why never
ask the Bible from l as i you the
cst the sun
d as lied yes it is a u se n ith 28 18
20 in heaven and on eth has been given to me there to
go and make
disciples all nations baji them in the name of the
Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit and
teaching them to obey everything I have
commanded you and surely I am with you loved
to the very end of the  These are two verses
from the Bible the first one said that
Jesus called the Son of God you say that Jesus is the Son
of God and second he said that
Jesus said to the nations what he said in the
ending last verse of the
Gospel of Matthew if you go further the
Gospel of Matthew chapter number 15 verse number
24 he said to the nations what he said in the ending last verse
of the Gospel of Matthew if you go further the Gospel of Matthew chapter number 15
verse number 24 he said to the nations what he said in the ending last verse of the Bible what he said is an interpolation but whether it is not I don't argue but then the construction in the Bible the Bible clearly mentions in the Gospel of Matthew chapter number 10 verse number 4 and
5 Jesus said to the nations what he said in the ending last
verse of the Bible ...  The
House of Israel as the first question
is concern the Jesus Christ who said that I am
the Son of God. Do you know in the
Bible God has got sons by the name
Adam was the son of God I am the son of God Israel is the son
of God All those who are led by the Spirit
of God are sons of God So if you are a true
person you are a son of God If I am a true
person I am a son of God That is the
language of the Bible as for calling son
of God to true person I do agree that since prophet
Jesus was the messenger of God he should be
called the son of God But what do
the Christian missionaries say no he is
not a normal son he is the beginning son and quote the
Bible Gospel of John chapter number verse number
16 for God the soul of the world the only
beginning son who should not perish by ever
lasting life  So what we have to realize is that
this verse of the Bible is based on the following verses: If
you read the
RSV Revised verse, they say this is
because of the Bible, so don't become a prophet, but become a prophet. It is because of the
action of the prophet, so don't become a prophet. So, I am
grateful to Allah for not only making this program possible, but also
for creating this opportunity
for a better understanding on
the topic for the millions of people other than those present here
watching us on television. We may,
insha'Allah, share some of the learnings
from this talk and question answer session with
others so that they can gain better understanding and we
thank all those who have
contributed.  and made this program
practically possible for all present here
today and for its telecast and those who have come
to attend this program jajak la
khar